you know this used to be the GOP I think  the United States are available in  you know I mean to make basic elementary  education you know to make the school  system relate to the prison system  and the of the you know  and so of course the results are the  work is also what is the work you know  it's not a question of blaming anybody  it's not everybody because we all and so  and demonize everyone complain we all  share the same responsibility for the  situation so we won't have to move and  stop fighting each other and call each  other horrible names do something that  makes a real difference and that  everyone  it's the next place with the core of  what is civil society which is respect  for each other ability to treat each  other with decency ability to find  something admirable in their works and  what is really which is the plan so  please this is the time don't wait